now george plimpton discusses his most
recent book truman capote in which
various friends enemies acquaintances
and detractors recall his turbulent
career
he talks about the people he interviewed
for the book and how he edited their
recollections together to tell the story
of capote's life
george plimpton is the author of more
than 20 books and the editor of the
paris review he spoke at printers inc
bookstore in palo alto california
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much for those
kind remarks
this
book truman capote is the third
oral biography that i've worked on the
first was called
american journey the life and times of
robert f kennedy
an autobiography which involved
interviewing the people who were on the
funeral train
uh from new york to uh washington
along with some other people who were
strongly identified with his life
uh the second one was called edie
which was about
a young girl named edie sedgwick
who was born of a very uh patrician
new england family
and had every advantage in life very
beautiful quite talented in some ways
but uh
sort of drifted down through the various
interesting worlds of the 60s
andy warhol's factory and eventually
ended up
out here in the motorcycle gangs of
buena vista
and died at that magical age of
28.
uh this last one is uh
about truman capote
he interested me because if you're going
to do an oral biography you ought to
find somebody who
is interesting in themselves
and who has surrounded himself through
his life with interesting people
truman capote was born in alabama
monroeville alabama was where he was
brought up a small town of only sixteen
hundred people
and quite odd to think that his
next-door neighbor was harper lee
of to kill a mockingbird quite
astonishing to think that these two
authors of
high repute came from the same town not
only that but living next door
to each other
some people indeed think that truman
capote had something to do with
to kill a mockingbird i rather doubt it
the styles are so entirely different
towards the end of his life truman
was very bitter about harper lee because
she won the pulitzer prize for to kill a
mockingbird
uh truman capote never won
the pulitzer prize or the national book
award for inco blood
it was said that one of the judges
thought it was too
uh commercial a book
i thought what i would do is read little
snatches of this book
this autobiography on truman
uh little portraits of the man uh
and um ones that um i thought perhaps in
reading would give you some sense of the
style of this mag of this book and
something about him
it's a i've tried to describe this this
book a little bit as if you wanted into
a cocktail party a huge cocktail party
at which were invited all of truman's
friends and enemies
uh and that they were all arranged
somehow chronologically these groups
and that you would first talk or
overhear people from monroeville alabama
uh talking and then
the people of his early life in new york
when he was a copy boy for the new
yorker
then at yaddo where he went the writer's
colony near saratoga
then perhaps to the black and white ball
in the plaza hotel
and then
in holcomb kansas
where he went to do the research from in
cold blood
uh then to meet the swans
the
high society folk that he
uh in whose houses he frequented
and then what happened when he turned
against him in this rather strange
almost aristotelian era
in which he felt that he could charm
them with what he wrote but indeed he
did not and then throw through the slow
descent
studio 54
and then finally joanne carson's house
on sunset boulevard
where he died
this is andreas brown talking about him
andreas brown is the curator of the
gotham bookmark in new york one of the
few last independent bookstores there
andres brown a capote's mother
lilie mae fork was said to be a great
southern beauty
not in the sense that we consider great
beauties today
but at that time she was considered a
very attractive and charming woman
by all accounts the prettiest girl
thereabouts
just an inch or so above five feet dark
blonde hair barely 17
but today what we might refer to as a
bubble head
she certainly was irresponsible
childlike
a case of arrested development in the
senate that she pursued adolescent
values well into her thirties
she married the first fellow that came
along who had any money arch persons
and abandoned her son truman to her
relatives when he was about two
just a baby really
and went off hoping to live the high
life with her husband
she won a beauty contest sponsored by
lux
one of many many regional winners
capote expanded this of course into her
winning the contest of miss alabama
in the miss america contest a typical
capote exaggeration
eventually she divorced her husband left
her child in monroeville alabama with
the forks
and went off to new york to seek fame
and fortune
in monrovia she would visit her son very
briefly
sometimes for a day
but she didn't stay very long
monroeville alabama
was not her idea
of glamour
this is nancy robinson a young woman a
young girl in monroeville remembers this
about truman
one time i went with truman next door to
see harper lee
we played in the yard for a long time
climbing the china berry trees
and we got really hot and tired
we went into the house to a back bedroom
where nell's father had an office
there was an old typewriter on the desk
in the room and they'll grab some paper
and put it in the typewriter truman
started telling a story and while he
talked nell typed it
well they would not let me help with the
story so i'd grab my paper dolls
and went home
[Applause]
this is natalie murray who was an editor
and a writer
he was hired as a messenger and an
office boy for the art department in the
new yorker magazine
one of his duties was to sharpen pencils
he was bringing his pencils back to the
studio
when howard ross the editor encountered
him
he turned around looked at truman and
asked what's that
truman walking down the corridor with
his pencil
looked like a little ballerina
he went there in the yard
the writer's colony near saratoga
uh carson mccullis was there at the time
leo lemon who became a great editor
mademoiselle
here's leo lemon
we played murder a great deal
that game where the ace of spades is the
murderer
and the jack of hearts is the detective
and you mill around in the dark hiding
and scared that the person next to you
may turn out to be the murderer
one night at murder it was an
extraordinary night very full of clouds
and a great moon
and we were all scared because we were
playing in this great hulking mansion
where we weren't supposed to be
i was the murderer
i knew exactly what victim i wanted
truman
everybody flew from room to room
screeching hiding here hiding there
casting the colors adored it she gave
screeches we all screeched she moved
when she had to move she wasn't sick in
those days slightly ossified but she
wasn't sick
we hid here we hid here and we hid there
and conjected about who the murderer was
being the sinister creatures i am
i enjoyed every minute of it
finally
i lured truman into my closet
and i strangled him
he screamed oh i'll get you for this
i'll never trust you again
it was absolutely thrilling his scream
went up several octaves above and
several octaves below it was the full
rage of truman
it was the manly truman the female
truman it was the works
i think the screen
haunts yaddo still
truman um
then of course other voices of the rooms
came out his first novel
with the famous picture of him on the
back
uh lying on a sofa looking
12 years old
it was a picture he always said that he
had not orchestrated but in fact he had
uh the novel was a huge success he went
abroad for the first time he spent a lot
of time traveling truman
here he is in paris this is by carl
bissinger who was a great photographer
paris at that time was jammed with young
americans living there they were
everywhere that summer sometimes you
wouldn't even hear french spoken in a
restaurant
so that evening after spending some time
at evenisage
we went to this little restaurant on the
rue dragon to get as far away as we
could from the constant chatter of
american voices
truman was in high spirits he was
everybody's darling
sporting that long bronzini scarf he
wore whatever the weather
he swept into the restaurant and he took
the table in the back
truman had begun telling stories and
telling them very well
when suddenly from the front of the
restaurant some guy a red-faced very
drunk american called out something to
the effect of for christ's sake wherever
i go i hear that american [ __ ] pansy
voice
can i ever get away from you guys
he must have been kind of half-assed
educated because i remember him saying
what the hell kind of dorian gray voice
is that anyway
the usual thing then at least was to
ignore such people but not truman he
bristled and got up
he started shaking his finger at the man
at the bar shouting at him in that high
crazy voice just you shut up
wherever you go you cause fights and
trouble fights in trouble just you shut
up don't wreck people's lives stop
calling people [ __ ]
on and on this phantom rooster what was
interesting was that there was this
general swell of approval from the
french
quite solid and though they probably had
no idea what was being said
they supported truman's performance
and you could tell it worked
the guy hopped down off his stool and
slunk out of the restaurant
then truman sat down and continued his
story exactly where he had let off
no comment on what had happened he just
was not to be troubled by the
philistines
he had a marvelous sense of justice
i don't actually know whether it was a
form of gay pride before there was such
a thing but it certainly was a form of
courage
and a demonstration of his own
convictions
this is uh david jackson who was a poet
a great friend of james merrow
and this is in stonington connecticut
he had a blue t-shirt that kept riding
up on his trunk not tucked in his pants
the village had never seen anything like
that a bare midriff
the shopkeepers edged towards the door
and peered out
his beach clothes had been designed for
him by chaparelli
it was a sort of a faux baseball suit
he was very amusing that summer we all
adored him if you had him for dinner an
evening of talk
he had these glasses he'd bring along a
clear pair
a slightly shaded pair and a really dark
pair
it was quite apparent that he couldn't
lie properly unless his eyes were
covered
so he would change glasses
when they were really dark you know a
huge exaggeration a lie was coming
we call them the shades of truth
the duponts have a house over there on
fish's island and when they gave a lunch
they sent over this massive boat for
truman
he was very pleased with himself when he
came back he said that there had been
100 for an outdoor lunch
medium shaded glasses
there had been a young girl there in her
teens hundreds of girls it was the
mating season we're certainly around the
dark
as lunch went on this girl was dying to
go down to the dock and look at the
gulls
everyone said no don't they're very
vicious at this time of year
darker glasses
finally she went with an umbrella to
watch them on the darks the umbrella
collapsed in the wind and the gulls
tried to peck her eyes out
darkest darkest shade
this is uh i i did this this is i tried
to speak into a tape recorder and then
of course did some editing to make it
sound absolutely terrific
this is about the
these women these people he called his
swans
he called them his swans for their
beauty their elegance
their charm and that's unsurprisingly
because they all seem to be endowed with
long necks
ray paley marella agnelli gloria
vanderbilt gloria guinness cece guest
lee radziwill slim keith
bay paley was to use a completely
inappropriate term the leader of the
pack slim elegant or remarkable beauty
she was surely the most undisheveled
person imaginable
so groomed everything perfectly in place
whether she was sitting in a companion
on the lido or hosting a fancy dinner
it would be difficult to imagine it
being tossed about by a strong wind
she would remain as unruffled as the
figurehead on the bow of a ship
billy baldwin the society decorator once
said of babe paley so great is her
beauty that no matter how often i see
her
each time is the first time
this is still me
babe haley came into his life in the mid
50s
the story was that the david selznick
invited down to the paley's place in
round hill jamaica by private plane
had asked if they could bring truman
along
the paley said absolutely it would be in
our it would be our honor thinking of
the cells inks were referring to harry
truman
one can imagine the paley's surprise
the former president to walk through the
door
of the plane and getting instead of
squeaky boys personage trailing a long
scar his mischievous face under a wide
brim straw hat
but of course they all got along
famously i doubt it took more than a few
minutes for babe to be absolutely
enchanted by him
this is uh jan cushing's
she was a great friend of his
the only time he ever tried to do
something funny
was when someone came in that i brother
fancied at the time and truman said
let's make him jealous
he lunged over and gave this gigantic
gave me this gigantic french kiss
i said truman honestly and moved away
he was joking
i met truman at a dinner that lester
pesky was having at the four seasons i
was seated next to truman
we started talking about psychiatrists
are you going to a psychiatrist truman
asked me i said yes
he asked me the psychiatrist's name and
truman said oh i know him well he's
terrible
let's play a trick on him
well what type of trick i asked
i'll set it up he said when you go to
the office tomorrow you say to the
doctor i've finally found the man of my
dreams i don't need you anymore
that's all you have to do do it about 11
o'clock
the next day i walked in and sat down i
said doctor i finally found everything
you told me to look for in life
i've found the man of my dreams
the doctor said i'm so happy mrs cushing
that you have i'm so happy that you've
listened
at which point
in walks the nurse dead white and ashen
and she says doctor mrs cushing's
fiancee has arrived
two seconds later in walks truman
outfitted with a cape and he screams
darling you stuck out of bed without
waking me i'm so unhappy i miss you so
the doctor almost went into a faint
he dropped his pencil
truman said bye bye doctor and he walked
out with his arm around me
that was my first experience with truman
and the last time i ever saw that
psychiatrist
this is slim keith one of the swans
he called me up one day
the new york has given me a choice of
assignments he said i can either follow
a day lady around new york who never
sees the people she works for and write
portraits of them just as just by what i
see
or i can go to kansas where they've been
some murders
which one do you think i ought to do
do the easy one i said go to kansas
the
um he took harper lee with him out to uh
kansas where the clutter murders had
taken place
a family of four
uh wiped out by
uh two uh drifters
uh perry smith and dick hickox
um truman did not make a particularly
good impression on some of the
agents out there
uh this is why harold nye held it
against him
how do we invited me to come up and meet
this gentleman who'd come to town to
write a book
so the four of us
kbi agents went up to his room that
evening after we had dinner
and here he is in a kind of new pink
negligee
silk with lace
and he's strutting around the floor
across the floor with his hands on his
hips telling us all about how he's going
to write this book
harper lee was there she had the room
next to truman absolutely fantastic
lydia i really liked her very much
but i did not get a very good impression
of that little son of a [ __ ]
we go up there and he's parading around
in his negligee it was not a good
impression and that impression never
changed
there's one thing i'll throw at you
which will kind of give you the way i
feel the way i do
my wife is a very strict individual
always has been she's as straight as an
arrow
usually we went with me she went with me
down to the mulenback hotel downtown
where we had dinner and talked okay
one time when he came truman asked if we
wanted to go out and look at kansas city
go out for the evening well sure you
don't turn him down so first we got a
cabin just off the main street
about a block and a half off 35th in
city sticks
we go up there and there's a discussion
where he pays 100 bucks to get us into a
place above a gallery to watch what's
going on in a lesbian bar
now here is what it was they were eating
tables dancing probably a hundred people
in their female couples doing their
thing
this was horrible to my wife she tried
to turn away from it but she didn't dare
say anything to truman
we leave
and he takes us over to a male gay bar
and we go in there
we sit down at a little table and order
a drink and it isn't three minutes until
some of these young bucks nail him
talking to him playing with his ears
just right in front of my wife
but how the hell do you say anything to
a man as famous as truman capote that
you don't like what he's doing
this went on for a little bit we finally
tried to excuse ourselves and leave
but truman guesses to go on to the jewel
box a little theater
and there i expect there must have been
30 female impersonators in there
and they're damn good
i mean they looked as good as any
beautiful babes in new york
but at the end of their little skits
they reveal that they were males
now to take this lady my wife
and truman knew what kind of a lady she
was because he had been to my house and
subjected to this
well his stock went down for us from 60
to about 10.
ben truman of course gave his famous
black and white ball
in new york in the plaza hotel
this is catherine graham
who he gave the ball for
who was then
the new publisher of the washington post
a very shy
woman her husband had committed suicide
and she was just taking over the reins
of this huge empire
and something that was very hard for her
for her to do and indeed her daughter
told me not long ago that this ball
had changed her from her a rather shy
withdrawn person into someone of
substance
and this is her recollection of how this
all began
truman called me up that summer and said
i think you need cheering up and i'm
going to give you a ball
well i said i don't need cheering up and
what are you talking about
i was totally baffled
he said yes i've always had this idea
for a black and white boy
he told me that he'd always loved the
black and white scene at the racetrack
in my fair lady
also he said that he loved the ballroom
in the plaza and always wanted to have a
party there
i was still sort of baffled but then he
got rolling with it and the publicity
got started
i felt a little bit the truman was going
to give the ball anyway
and that i was part of the props perhaps
a prop is unfair
but i felt that he needed a guest of
honor and with a lot of imagination he
figured out
me
this is uh lewis lapin who went to the
ball and the editor of
harper's magazine
i passed through the police barricades
in front of the plaza and listened to
pete hamill among others shouting me
that this is the beginning of the end
that the tumbles will soon be rolling
he was then a new york post reporter and
he was speaking for the songku lot
that this was all too brash and arrogant
a display of wealth and celebrity
and it was being thrown in the teeth of
the democrats in the streets and so
forth
i remember the evening being
extraordinary for one reason
at most new york parties there's always
a degree of anxiety it was good to be
there but was one at the right table or
was or was one being seen at the right
end of the room over the right people
but on this occasion every table was the
right table simply to be present was to
be for the time
safe for the time being safe on the high
and sunny plateau
so all the tables were equally fine and
everybody was just pleased to be present
then i noticed this extraordinarily
beautiful woman whom i later found out
was luciana pinatelli
she had some sort of a career as an
italian model
who was somehow associated with the
italian utmond
clearly she had that manner
i remember that she was wearing an
immense jewel
an emerald or ruby possibly a diamond in
the middle of her head
she wore a kind of head ribbon
and in the center of it was this great
stone
i don't know whether it had come from
india or had once been worn by an
elephant or the zarina of russia
but it was clearly a stone that had a
history empires had perished many had
died in order to provide this brilliance
for the head of luciana pinatelli
i noticed that every time she moved or
danced or glittered in the light
about three guys were standing around
whose eyes never left her forehead
she had more security than any of the
kennedys present
apparently she had borrowed this jewel
from harry winston
and winston had let it out of his sight
only on the condition that it was
followed by three heavies with guns
at the end of the party
johnny agnelli wanted to go someplace
and play poker
it was two in the morning
one of the places to play poker at that
hour was elaine's
among the cognizant or the friends of
gianni as they were known someone had
suggested why don't we all go to a lanes
and play cards
somehow i ended up in the same limousine
with luciana who was part of his
entourage
she was not wearing the jewel
the guards had removed this thing from
her forehead
i may be exaggerating maybe she went
tastefully into the ladies room put it
into a portable safe and presented to
the guards that way
a lead-lined casket
in any case the jewel did not get into
the car it didn't get out of the hotel
and it never graced elaine's
this is a little poem that john sargent
wrote about the party found it in his
diary
he was the publisher of double day at
one point
in my diary i have this curious poem
i have no idea whose it is it just sits
there
truman capati
is not nearly as dotty
as some of the people who went to his
party
this is a piece about truman by judy
green uh the novelist who which i think
tells you something about this
about truman that is about as well said
as anybody in the book i think
one of the wonderful things about truman
was he always had the element of little
boy wonder in him and that's a
delightful characteristic in someone
as jaded as his appetites where his
surprise and wonderment never ceased
if someone paid him a compliment
he was thrilled
it was as if it were for the first time
of course other times he'd say i started
this new kind of journalism and i'm the
greatest there ever was
but still
the little boy wonder was there
imagine someone who was brought up in
very shabby circumstances
suddenly coming into the rolling lawns
of long island
and being accepted where gatsby never
was
truman didn't have the yachts
or the house across the sound or the
looks or the money
yet people were crazy about him
to reach the apogee of acceptance with
his black and white boy while he was
more than just a darling he was a social
lion an arbiter
if you weren't invited to truman's ball
and he didn't accept you that was a
black mark in society
and to reach that level
i mean it's almost an insanity it's a
fluke it's weird
was he a product of the times would it
have happened in eduard in england god
no
who would ever dictate like that
he was fopia than any of them i mean
noah coward couldn't have done it
oscar wilde if he'd stayed out of
trouble couldn't have done it there were
writers who wanted it f scott fitzgerald
wanted it at one time john o'hara was
desperate
truman used all of his physical
disabilities his attributes
the voice the body the hand movements
the tongue
and then
the metamorphosis took place from prince
to frog
the swoleness that took over his whole
body that was grotesque
and still boy his face with that swollen
strange look
but i never knew him when he wasn't
sweet to me
odd
he said to me you know people have a
look and they have to keep it
and when you keep a look you never grow
old
the reason that he turned
well i'll read one more then i'll tell
you what happened this is richard brooks
the director who made inco blood the
film
when we arrived at lawrence
kansas where the university is
i met truman and asked him what he was
doing there
he said they put a stand out on the
football field the students are going to
come and i'm going to talk to them
about what i asked i'm going to read
some poetry and my christmas story
you're going out to a football field and
you're going to read poetry to these
people at night outside
yes why not he asked i turned to tom
shaw my assistant director and i said
see if you can get a couple of police
because i think they're going to lynch
him
we went out there that night and there
were about 15 goddamn thousand people
and to see this guy who wrote the book
who's four foot one with blonde hair and
he's going to read poetry
they couldn't get any police i said to
tom why don't you get on one side of the
stand and i'll stand on the other
and if they start coming for him we can
get him the hell out of there
tom's a pretty rough looking guy
between the two of us we were going to
take care of capote
so
he starts to read this stuff and what
happens
not only do they not walk out of the
stadium under the football field but by
the time he's finished fifteen thousand
people are cheering and roaring like
he's a football player
it was the most amazing experience and i
realized that this guy was a superstar
i really thought there was going to be
violence
not a chance they loved him they were
going to carry him on their shoulders
like a winning football coach
well truman
then wrote this
or published part of this novel that he
was working on
which was called um answered prayers
and in it he
told a lot of sort of secrets of the
swans
about their peccadillos and particularly
their husbands
and it destroyed him in their eyes and
they threw him into coventry
and they turned their backs on him slim
keith babe paley
all those people i named earlier with
the one exception of lee radziwill who
stayed with him
and it was a dreadful time for him
because i think he wanted more than
anything else to be part of this world
uh he began to drink
he began to drink very heavily he also
moved into drugs and so forth he came
out here to california on occasion
to do film scripts
and here he is um this is dachshund
raider a writer
who describes a
meeting that he had with peggy lee the
great
singer
who
used to be known as miss standing
ovation
truman was a great jazz buff and peggy
lee was one of his favorite singers
so i called up peggy he was a friend of
mine and i said i'm here with truman and
we'd love to take you to dinner are you
free tomorrow
she said yes why don't you come around
for a drink around six typical la they
eat like farmers
she sends her car for us the house is in
ballet and it's got an enormous front
door one of these modern houses with a
lot of glass and stone
there's some trouble getting the door
unlocked so we stand there for a while
then we walked in there's the biggest
living room i ever saw in my life in the
longest sofa typical hollywood two floor
ceilings
peggy lee can press a button on a
console buyer and the screen comes down
the projector turns on that sort of
thing it's an enormous dramatic
theatrical hollywood kind of place
at one end is a solid line of glass
sliding doors overlooking her gardens
peggy is dressed in a very thin white
chiffon gown
peggy hadn't been too well she moved
very slowly because she had her oxygen
tent with it
truman takes one look at it and goes oh
my god i'm in the presence of an angel
he goes over to her she doesn't move he
takes her hand and kisses one finger
she says can i get you something to
drink and truman says he wants a vodka
and i say i'll have the same
she buzzes for a man to come to get his
drinks he looks sort of bewildered
because she doesn't keep any liquor in
the house
he brings his perrier water now that
irritates truman he wants a drink
peggy says to him well truman can i show
you the gardens
so he says well all right show me the
gardens but then we've got to go
he really wants a drink
she goes over to the sliding glass doors
and she can't get them open
so truman says let me help
so the two of them peggy wasn't very
steady and this little guy are tugging
and kicking and pulling trying to get
these doors open
and we never did get them open
so then we go to a restaurant which is
one of the most pretentious restaurants
in america so it's very popular in los
angeles
it has started to pour it came down cats
and dogs once in the restaurant truman
and i ordered drinks and peggy orders a
bottle of avian water for which i paid
fifty dollars
it came in a silver champagne holder
we are trying to hold a conversation in
a room which has a tin roof
so you feel like you're on the western
front in world war one
and the germans are machine gunning your
lives we can barely hear a thing truman
and peggy and i are shouting back and
forth at each other trying to make
conversation
suddenly peggy says to truman do you
believe in reincarnation
and truman says well i don't know do you
she says oh yes i've been reincarnated
many times
in my other lives i've been a prostitute
a princess an abyssinian queen
and truman sort of looks at her and says
well how do you know all this
and she says i can prove it
i remember being a prostitute in
jerusalem when jesus was alive truman
says oh really what else do you remember
oh she said i remember the crucifixion
very well
truman says oh
she says yes i'll never forget picking
up the jerusalem times
and seeing the headline jesus christ
crucified
at that point she gets up to go to the
bathroom
and truman looks at me and says she's
totally bonkers
you've got to remember all this is
shouted over the machine gunning going
on
she comes back and they start talking
about singers and truman asks when she
got started
then something happened i noticed a lot
with truman he would meet someone make
fun of them although they weren't aware
of it and then suddenly they would say
something that would reveal a
vulnerability
some heartache or pain and suddenly
truman's attitude would change
one of the reasons he got along with a
lot of people was it was that they were
open with him rather than being
compatible
i think that's one of the reasons he
became to hate the rich
because with the exception of his few
closest friends like babe paley they
were never open with him they were not
never vulnerable around him
unless he knew a vulnerability of yours
he never felt safe around you
anyway they were talking about singers
in the 40s and she started talking about
her mother who weighed 360 pounds and
used to beat her up and her father and
used to beat up her father all the time
and her as well
when she was 11 her mother took a [ __ ]
butcher knife and stabbed her in the
stomach and she said she still had the
scar
she started singing when she was 14 or
15 at this radio station in fargo north
dakota
and i forgot who heard it one of the
band leaders jimmy or tommy dorsey and
they brought it to chicago to perform at
the pump room at the ambassador east
she arrived a couple of days early with
a girlfriend they had very little money
she was scared of the town
they checked into a motel
she was so naive she didn't realize that
the fleabag they had checked into was a
whorehouse
she said all these painted girls going
up and down all the time it never dawned
on me the people did that sort of thing
when they showed up at the ambassador
east mr dorsey put them into a hotel
room
and for a week until she got her first
paycheck
she and her girlfriend would stay up
late so that around 11 or 12 o'clock at
night when people had put their room
service trays outside in the hall
they would go down the hall and collect
buns and butter
they didn't know that you could use room
service
this story touched truman he suddenly
became very protective of her his whole
attitude changed and he asked if she
could sing something
here we are in the restaurant where the
bill ended up being 300
and truman and peggy lee sat there
another 30 or 40 minutes totally
oblivious to everyone around them
including me
singing songs bye bye blackbird i'll be
seeing you in all these old standards
and all the way back in the car
they talked about music
and every once in a while the two of
them would start singing
it was a lovely evening
all right just two more here
uh truman
uh spent his last um
uh days with joanne carson who was one
of the
uh wives of johnny carson they're all
called joanne i think this was number
two
and this is a description that i
remember from uh going there
joanne carson's is set back
joanne carson's house is set back on a
steep slope with a very treacherous
driveway just off sunset boulevard a
garden of roses out front with a small
swimming pool under the overhanging
branches of a eucalyptus tree
joanne said the temperature of the pool
was kept bathtub warm truman enjoyed
sitting on the top step
slightly submerged holding forth by the
hour on summer days
joanne took me through the house one
story rambling
and with so much foliage backed up
against the windows that it had a quite
wonderful wondrous twilight feeling
about it like walking along the floor of
a rainforest
quite romantic and cozy
to help with the lighting every room had
an array of votive candles on tables on
the flagging usually in clusters varied
varied sizes like organ pipes
joanne told me that when she and truman
had a party it took a half hour moving
through the rooms to get them all going
joanne said she used the candles for
parties when people came over
but truman felt that they were their
best guests
so they always had the candles lit
when they were alone
this is again truman
and
joanne
in the very last days before he died in
this room in the back
we would go on these marvelous imaginary
adventures he'd call me up from new york
and say tomorrow we're going to paris
and i would pick him up at the airport
we would come home
i would put my answer phone on and
cancel anything i had for the next day
and when i woke up in the morning he
would bring in a tray with croissants
and sugar cubes from the ritz hotel
and little jars of marmalade from the
hotel creon which of course he lifted
then we take out books from the rhodam
museum books from the louvre and we take
a trip there
now we're going to have lunch he'd say
he'd pick a restaurant and we'd have a
french-style cuisine here to match
and so he would spend a whole day in
paris without moving
we did the same thing with china
we went to spain we went to mexico italy
and england
for the china trip he brought these
little painted earthenware medicine jars
we'd have chinese food
we'd sit by the fireplace on the floor
to have dinner
and then we'd look at the maps of china
he'd say
today we're going to shanghai and here's
what we're going to see
and we would look through the books he
brought
i don't know how he did it he spent
months putting these things together
before we'd go on a trip
china was very important to him
it was the only country he hadn't
actually been to
well there you are
[Applause]
[Music]
well you've been very patient i thought
we could have some questions if you'd
like to have me answer anything i can
answer you about um truman or about
anything else for that matter yes
[Applause]
well the question is uh not about truman
uh but about participatory journalism
which i'm supposed to invented uh but
it's not so i didn't invent it at all
i got enormously interested in a man
named paul gallico
when i began writing for sports in the
street paul gallico
uh was a sports writer the most heavy
the most uh highly paid sports writer in
the country
and he worked in the so-called golden
age of sport it was the time of babe
ruth and
red grange and jack dempsey was the
heavyweight champion of the world
and paul gallico felt that it was very
important if you were a sports writer to
try to find out about sports at the very
highest level that it wasn't fair
to criticize somebody for striking out
on the bottom of the ninth bases loaded
world series unless you yourself had
seen
how devastating a major league curveball
is
and so uh
paul gallacher climbed down out of the
press box so to speak and he set himself
up a whole series of confrontations
he caught her panic skirt ball he was a
great pitcher for the yankees back then
he played a tennis with vinnie richards
who was bill tilden's partner
or a rival he uh
got into the ring with jack dempsey
uh dempsey was a man who didn't
particularly like to find other people
in the ring with him and so gallica was
only in there for about 32 seconds
very little to write about the next day
couldn't remember very much
what else did he do he went down the
olympic ski run at garmish overseas
which was quite a feat because he'd
never been on skis before
and he wrote
a book
rather predictably entitled farewell to
sport
and he went on to write popular novels
he wrote the poseidon adventure
and in this book um
there's this chapter called the feel
and it's about these various adventures
that uh he had
he said
impartially an answer to what you at the
second question he said the most
terrifying thing that happened to him
of all these participatory things was
quite odd
it was writing in the uh in the
locomotive coming through gary indiana
at 60 miles an hour going through all
those switchbacks and and
in the railroad yards and that terrified
him oddly more than being in the ring
with jack dempsey
any case i read this thing when i began
working for sports illustrated and i
wondered
if it wouldn't be
possible to do the same sort of thing
but at greater depth
you know to join a football team rather
than just catching a punt
or
and so i went to the editors of sports
illustrated and they
said fine it's been done before playing
out the daydreams at all american males
seem to suffer
it was james thurber who said that 95 of
american men
put themselves to sleep at night
striking out the batting order of the
new york yankees
i have no idea what women they dream
about to put themselves asleep perhaps
we can confer
later on and they
began to help me set these things up and
they involved playing quarterback with
the detroit lions and
pitching to and all pitching in an
all-star game in the yankee stadium and
getting myself terribly beaten up by
archie moore who was a light heavyweight
champion of the world all of this to
write books
and i've done many books on that
particular subject
so that's the uh the first part of the
quest and the most terrifying thing to
me
oddly
a little bit i suppose like paul
gallacher when the railroad switchings
and so forth the one that terrified me
more than any of the other things that i
did was playing with the new york
philharmonic
i played the triangle with the new york
philharmonic
and some of the percussion instruments
and of course the reason it was so
terrifying was that in music
you cannot make a mistake you know sport
is all predicated on the idea that
somebody is going to make and make an
error you know
you can't but you can't have a sport
without somebody making making an error
but in music if you make an error you
destroy
a piece of art
and uh
i destroyed um
a number of symphonies
poor old leonard bernstein he was the
conductor at the time he couldn't fire
me because i was
a documentary was being made of this
stint with the new york philharmonic so
i would destroy
let's say marla's fourth symphony
and uh but i was he was stuck with me
nothing you can do about it for one
terrifying month probably more
terrifying for him than it was for me
yes
[Music]
the question was what was tomokopode's
stature i would guess he was a little
bit taller than maybe an inch taller
than five feet and maybe a little under
there
built like a sword or shotgun as uh
norman miller used to say rather behave
like one every once in a while
he had a wonderful a very handsome face
and a a normal sort of body but his legs
were like a truck driver's legs very
powerful
uh he used to he was very powerful he
hand wrestled uh humphrey bogart for an
example on the seto to beat the devil
and threw him to the floor
uh his voice was this uh almost
everybody in new york can imitate his
voice but i can't it's a
high with a lisp uh his tongue used to
sort of wall out of his mouth a little
bit
uh his voice was was so high that as
gore vidal once pointed out it could
only be understood by dogs
he uh he had a number of relationships
all with men
his uh his first great love was a man
called newton arvin
who was a professor at smith college and
was at yardo
and had a lot to do with the um
education of truman in a sense taught
him the greeks and the classics
his long-term lover
was a man called jack dunphy who was an
irishman
a an actor he was married to joan
mccracken
who starred in uh oklahoma
and uh stayed with him a stable the only
stable thing in his life was probably
jack dunapy
uh he he left jack dunphy a number of
times usually to fall in love with
middle-aged irishmen with large families
one of the one of these one of the
families was the o'shea family
and i think one of the most one of the
most touching parts of this book it's
the longest monologue in it in fact
there's a whole chapter devoted to this
young girl named kate
kate o'shea her name was and when john
o'shea her father went off with truman
it disrupted the family as you might
guess
and the family began to fall apart
and kate who was the youngest of the
five children
called up truman in new york and said i
need your help
and he invited her to come to new york
and
she
stayed in his apartment for two years
he uh longer than that he took around to
the modeling agencies and she was only
13 at the time
i took around a dick avadon who took
pictures of her an extraordinary
portfolio and tried to do the very best
that he could to give some sort of a
to stabilize her life somewhat
took her out to hollywood and introduced
her all the people out there and tried
to make an actress of it
i changed her name
from o'shea to harrington that was not
done by him but it was done by one of
the by wilhelmina
one of the modeling
agencies and in this book i tried to
find her for a long time and then one
day she recognized me on the street came
up and said my name is kate harrington
and we went off and i talked to her for
listen to her for about three hours
and her monologue is in this book almost
as she spoke about what it was like
to spend this time with
with truman in his house
and keeping a journal which she did
uh an astonishing portrait sort of
a pygmalion attempt on his part to help
her
some of the love affairs that
truman had were disastrous
people who were drunk
lovers who were drunk
and he had a very unhappy time with all
of them really
except uh jack dunphy who was his
uh faithful
lover they lived in saga panic long
island in separate houses
dunphy trying very hard for a long time
to stabilize his friend but unable to do
so at the end yeah
it's apparent from
uh gerald clark's biography of the book
that he worked extraordinarily hard on
equal blood to make the book extremely
accurate and it seems that he took great
pleasure in the inability of the new
yorker back checkers to find anything
the least bit inaccurate in the story
and i know he always insisted that it
was non-fiction but it also seems to be
true that if the clark book is to be
believed that in the end he compromised
in a crucial way and inserted a false
ending that is to say the scene with
which the book concludes apparently did
not occur and was a sort of fabrication
and
i i
can't help thinking that
this must also reflect the kind of
problem that you must have faced in your
work as a non-fiction writer the desire
to produce a sort of perfectly shaped
plotted thing out of life itself which
should sell the minutes i was curious to
know whether you have an opinion about
this problem yourself and whether you
learned anything about capote's attitude
well that's a very good question the
question of course has to do with uh if
you write non-fiction and you're
covering a story uh should you be
allowed to
embellish it and put on glasses of the
darker shade
the temptation there of course if you
write non-fiction is enormous
i like to think that i don't do
what you just described
um there are ways of shaping a story uh
and still tell the truth
um the ending of uh in cold truman used
to say that uh everything in the in in
cold blood was
accurate i did an interview with him for
the new york times in which he talked
about the non-fiction novel
and he i i asked him a question i said
in
your description of the long ride which
is what the two killers do after they
commit the murders
in holcomb kansas
and they only got about i forgot what
the amount of money was out of it but
they got nothing they committed the
murders because one of them had heard in
prison
that mr clutter kept ten thousand
dollars in a safe
and they went into this farmhouse and uh
murdered the whole family and then went
on this long ride and at one point he
truman writes about it the car in which
they were riding
swerving to miss a dog
and it's a wonderful device because a
chapter or so later you come back to
this dog swimming incident i asked him i
said did a dog really swerve i mean you
weren't there truman
and he said one does not write
the sort of honest uh non-fiction novel
that i've been trying here and make
errors of that sort
dick hickox who was one of the murderers
had according to truman an absolutely
rat-trapped mind and remembered
everything
perry smith the other murderer couldn't
remember anything he was very
interesting in his own right
but hickox had this extraordinary mind
and truman went and took the same
ride with them
not with them but the same places that
they had all been so that he could check
hit coxes
against his uh
also truman had this incredible memory
he never could remember whether it was
93
or 95 percent he sort of forgot what
percent uh he was able to remember from
conversations
now
that all given i have talked to people
uh about errors in cold blood
uh harold nye it was the fellow that he
took to the uh
the the gay bars and the and and so
forth told me that he did not get at all
right
uh an episode with a uh a housekeeper in
las vegas where the prisoners were
picked up
the ending of enco blood
i think i asked truman about that the
ending of in cold blood has this
alvin dewey
goes back to uh see his grandfather's
grave
and he runs into a young woman who would
have been nancy clutter's classmate
and he talks to her
and he sees her running down this path
and her hair is flying and he is
reminded of
nancy clutter who had been about the
same age and looked about the same
truman says that alvin dewey did go to
look at his grandfather's grave
and that at another time he had talked
to this girl
and so what he did was to combine these
two
now
if you're a purist uh he's fiddled a
little bit for dramatic effect
i don't think that happens very often in
that book
uh
truman of course uh
had to hope desperately that um the hang
of the people were hanged
uh what what was he going to do with the
with the book in case in case these two
killers got
a life imprisonment languishing away
so i think that every writer fashions
things or hope things will happen which
will make it dramatic
but i suspect that he came awfully close
to the truth in that book but truman you
know used to lie terribly now i remember
he was told me once
about another series of murders that he
was going to write about
murders in the western part of nebraska
there was a landowner
who was trying to get rid of some people
along the river bottom
and so one by one he began to
extinguish them
murdering them
and a truman swore to me that this was
all true
and
he said that one of the murders
that was thought up by the murderer
was to put two rattlesnakes
in the front of a car
and when the couple would come out of
church on a sunday in this little
nebraska town they would step into the
front seat
and that was the murder weapon with
these two rattlesnakes and i said truman
that doesn't make much sense to me i
mean that rattlesnakes first of all have
got rattles
and secondly
their poison is hemotoxic and it takes a
long time to have it
much effect
the next time i heard the story
the couple had suddenly increased in age
they were in their late 80s they were
teetering on the edge of death
not only that but the rattlesnakes had
their rattles removed and they were
laced with amphetamines
so
truman would swear this was so but this
was at a stage where
i think uh this was post uh in cold
blood
uh so who knows
your stories so that they have a plot
you can't deal with any other stories
how do you mean deal with other stories
um
well uh
if you're for example interested in a
person but the person's life or the
portion of the person's life we can
afford to talk about what we can gain
access to doesn't fit together can you
leave it out
i think there are way i'm for example
i've been sent out to new by the name
i'll tell you the story i'm working on
at the moment
now some of you and you may know about
this the new yorker is going to do a big
california issue
and some years ago about 12 years ago i
came out here to cover a story
about a man he was a vietnam war veteran
he was a cook
and he decided that he was going to fly
and he picked a most curious conveyance
to do this it was a lawn chair a deck
chair
to which he was going to attach some two
dozen odd helium filled weather balloons
and he was going to rise out of this
backyard in long beach uh california
and up to about 500 feet or so when he
had with him he was going to take with
him in the uh
launch with his lawn chair thing a
pistol air pistol and he was going to
pop these balloons and this was going to
regulate his altitude
and uh the great day came i went
actually to the garden where this
happened in long beach it's a place
about half the size of this room with a
bird bath at one end
and an iron flamingo at the other
and uh these tethering ropes were struck
and this
guy in the deck chair larry walters his
name is went up to 500 feet and he
reached with this air pistol
and it fell between his knees to the
ground
and he went up sixteen thousand nine
hundred people there's a deck chair
and he drifted into the air patterns of
lax
and
when i went out there to see him he had
he vanished i said i'd really like to
write about this an amazing story most
people don't believe this is a story
when i tell them they just don't believe
it
unfortunately their photographs and so
forth this guy in his deck chair he came
down about um
uh 23 miles from where he started came
down in the backyard of a policeman
who was sitting in his deck chair
reading a copy of the los angeles sunday
times
and uh now when i saw him i said i
wanted to write about it and he sent me
he gave me these transcripts of pilots
who had looked out the window at 16 000
feet
and seen a guy drifting by in a deck
chair
and um
so i have all this well unfortunately uh
about after i got all this information
larry walters
uh called me up one day in new york and
said you know this is my story and i'm
very anxious to speak about it in
aviation clubs and so forth please don't
write it
and so i had to honor him what he said
so i kept all this material for quite a
long while until tina brown was the
editor of the new yorker i was talking
about this one day and she said i'm
doing this california issue
please write it for me
and so i then had to find larry walters
i didn't know how to do that of course
his telephone number i had for him had
gone
and i met a man out here who has a nexus
whatever that extraordinary thing is
where you can find out anything but
anything on that thing in the internet
and he sent me a copy of what he
discovered that larry walters walked in
to the santa ana mountains
and shot himself through the heart with
a rifle a year ago
now this story
i have to think a lot about what you've
just asked me
is to i have fortunately i have
transcripts and so forth uh i can i have
a transcript of his girlfriend's fiance
trying to get him to come back down you
know come back she began shouting 50
feet above that you know above the
ground
well i've got to go and see her and i've
got to see but when you have a story
that wonderful you see the temptation to
um
to fix it a little bit to dramatize it
is always there
but uh you know particularly with the
new yorker you have to stick to the
facts i don't think that story has to be
embellished very much to you
yes
and i've seen that story on the internet
not quite with that
version of it well on the internet about
uh two months ago uh they the people in
new zealand who are not aware that he's
dead
uh gave him a a prize for being the
foolhardiest person of the year although
this thing happened 12 years ago
the father yes the question about was
about john o'shea john o'shea and truman
finally had a
terrific row and john o'shea escaped or
escaped us the wrong way but left with
truman's manuscript of answered prayers
so truman has always said
and uh and left and now lives in in
florida
uh that's i have i the last person i
really hope to see to do is o'shea
he's a great sports enthusiast and i
thought maybe because i'd written paper
lion and uh uh opennet and the bogeyman
and various other sports books that he
might like to talk to me and kate his
daughter thought that their relationship
had gotten much better and that this
might happen and then kate disappeared
[Music]
never came to the apartment when kate
was there they lived in california
together they went on trips together
they were in europe a lot on yachts and
so forth
yes
editing and
editing a autobiography
well what you do is you interview all
these people and then you try to break
the interviews down into uh categories
uh for example everybody that talks
about monroeville you put into a big
folder
and then what you do at least what i do
i have a pool table at home and you take
out these little sections
and you take them together uh i used to
call them pythons and some of them is
almost as long as this room
and then you clip and you move them
around until you think they have a flow
to them
it's not really writing as much as
stitching in a way it's like
putting a sort of mosaic together
and you have to hope that the thing has
a sort of a movement to it
uh like reading a novel really
i think one of the pleasures of of doing
this i'll give an example i read a long
piece about frank sinatra the other day
in the new yorker by john lehrer
and he went to a lot of the
la i guess it is
and i and i uh i kept thinking my
goodness he must have gotten all this
information on tape and how wonderful it
would be to listen to these raw
transcripts of what he uh when he was
talking to sinatra's music people
uh and i think that's the one advantage
of the oral biography is you get the raw
transcripts and if you know how to put
those into an order
it's really like as i was saying it's
like going to a cocktail party and
overhearing people talking
there are disadvantages
in that
you don't
really you can't
lead the reader if you use this sort of
method you have to put six views of one
thing
focused it's a little bit like the gates
of rashford and if you remember that
film in which you have five i've
forgotten how many or eight i guess it
was views of a particular incident that
takes place in the gates of rashford
so it's a bit hard to uh
to to tell the truth really because you
have all these divergent views
um and i think you have to let the chips
fall where they may i was very tempted
to leave out harold harold knight for an
example says that truman
at the hanging
fled when perry smith was hanged
his friend he become almost in fact
harold and i goes to say that they had a
love affair in the prison
charles mcaday was the head of the
prison was actually furious of this no
way that they could have had a love
affair in the prison
and so that then actually described to
me the octagonal shape of the death row
in the kansas city penitentiary
and that there was a opposite
perry smith was a terrible man for
andrews who hated him who would have
seen this and shouted and yelled
so do you leave out nine
because you know probably that perry
smith and truman did not have a physical
relationship in the prison
or do you let it sit
and it's a very difficult moral judgment
that one has to make
my my answer to all this was to let it
sit
makes it more exciting
yes
together and then looking back
well um never really thought about that
i suppose i would consider myself an
oral biographer a terrible phrase oral
biography norman mayweather said it
sound like infectious disease
i don't i don't know i suppose i would
consider myself a
stitcher of other people's uh
transcripts
a couple more yeah
that's very interesting the question was
why did truman write the uh this this
amazing story which appeared in coat
basque in esquire magazine was called
coat basque
seen in a restaurant
and one of the people the protagonist of
the story talks about the people sitting
around in this fancy
new york restaurant
and about the people coming in and out
and uh one of the stories for an example
was about ann woodward
who committed suicide right about that
time and some people think she was so
upset
by what she read in truman saying that
she threw herself out of the window
that was the story she was the wife of
bob woodward
william woodward
and she shot him with a shotgun you
remember in long island mistaking him
for a burglar
and it almost was almost pretty much
and truman it's interesting she had in
europe she had um
he had truman had overheard her
calling him a [ __ ]
and
he went like this at her
and this may have been his reason for
putting this
story in the coat bath uh there's
another story in there about uh babe
paley's husband
uh the most vivid uh thing you had to
guess who these people were but it was
pretty easy to guess who they were and
there he is in the st regis hotel
trying to do away with the evidence of a
liaison with a mistress
and people could guess who the mistress
was too mary rockefeller very likely
wife of the governor
this thing came out and it caused an
unbelievable stir
as you can imagine and it was when they
all turned against him now why did he do
this
well some people felt truman himself
felt that
they would be amused by all of this he
was a writer what else did they expect
uh
andreas brown has an interesting
idea
uh truman's mother
was in was in love with the idea of
becoming a member of high society
and uh
she married joe capote
and that's why truman's name is capote
and not persons changed his son's name
when he was two or three
uh she drove mr capote he was really
quite a successful businessman into
spending so much for an apartment on
park avenue and the high life
that he had to eventually embezzle money
from his firm uh from his company
and went to jail went to sing-sing
for uh six months or whatever it was
now is it possible the truman
realizing this realizing the false
values that his mother aspired to high
society took his revenge for his
mother's suicide
by writing this story in the uh the code
basque interesting notion
uh
my own feeling about it is that he
simply made a very bad mistake
he thought they would understand this
that
he had
been in their homes and they told him
all these stories why it wasn't and they
repeated these stories to each other
what was wrong with him putting it on
paper
and it was a bad mistake on his part
about box airs saturday nights at 8
eastern end pacific time and sundays at
9 p.m eastern end pacific